r
l'évolution de notre propre
planète. Normand Grondin.
- Deux nouvelles sondes
américaines, une européenne, des
projets russes, indiens et même
une mission financée par Rocket
Lab, une compagnie privée...
En quelques mois, la planète
Vénus est devenue la nouvelle
coqueluche de l'astronomie.
FRÉDÉRIQUE BARON, Institut
de recherche exoplanètes, UdeM
- Depuis à peu près un an,
toute la communauté a vraiment
tourné son regard vers Vénus
et on se demande : est-ce
qu'il y a de la vie maintenant
sur Vénus?
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ, directeur,
Planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
- On veut connaître l'histoire
de Vénus et, en connaissant
l'histoire de Vénus, on va
peut-être pouvoir connaître
un peu plus le futur
de la planète Terre.
- Plusieurs missions ont étudié
et cartographié cette planète
depuis les années 60, mais
seuls les Russes ont réussi
à se poser sur son sol,
à prendre des relevés,
des photos et même du son
provenant de la surface;
tout ça dans des conditions
infernales.
Sur Vénus, il fait 465 °C et
la pression atmosphérique est
de 93 bars, soit l'équivalent de
plus de 900 mètres de profondeur
sous l'océan.
- C'est dur, aller sur Vénus.
Quand on pense à Mars, Mars,
sur Mars, on a des astromobiles
qui sont là depuis des jours,
des mois, tout ensemble ça fait
des années. Sur Vénus, quand
on envoie une sonde à la surface
de Vénus, elle peut survivre
seulement quelques heures.
- Les missions que préparent
la NASA et l'Agence européenne
sont complémentaires.
Elles vont entre autres
cartographier avec une grande
précision la surface agitée
de Vénus, qui pourrait soutenir
une intense activité volcanique.
- On s'aperçoit que c'est
une planète qui a une géologie
très complexe et qui,
possiblement, possède
une tectonique très diverse et
très variée, avec des structures
qui n'existent pas ailleurs
dans le système solaire.
- Les chercheurs vont également
étudier l'épaisse couche de
nuages qui recouvre la planète,
résultat d'un effet de serre
format géant. Ensuite, ils vont
tenter de tracer un parallèle
avec ce qui se passe
présentement sur Terre.
- On essaye de comprendre
comment cette planète-là
a pu passer aussi rapidement
d'un état où elle pouvait
posséder à l'origine
de l'oxygène en plus grande
quantité à maintenant
une atmosphère qui semble
très... enfin, qui est
impossible pour la vie.
- Mais ce qui fascine le plus,
c'est la découverte récente
et controversée d'un gaz,
la phosphine, dans l'épaisse
couche de nuages qui recouvre
Vénus.
Là où il y a de la phosphine,
il pourrait y avoir de la vie.
- On pense qu'à à peu près
50 km au-dessus de la surface,
il pourrait y avoir de la vie;
on parle de vie microbienne ici,
vraiment de la vie toute petite,
et ça, c'est dû à cette
découverte de la phosphine,
une découverte qui a été faite
il y a à peu près un an.
- La compagnie Rocket Lab pense
que sa mission vénusienne sera
prête en 2023; la NASA vise
plutôt la fin de la décennie.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.